hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice blitz game from round eight of
the Tata Steel Indian edition of the
Grantchester every continent versus
Magnus Carlsen and as usual all all the
attention is on their board here you can
see all of the photographer
photographers trying to get as clean of
a shot as possible you know for for
later use
also courtesy of Leonard Oats Otis as as
usual the the photo so let's just enjoy
that for a moment there you have it now
let's check out the game so island with
the white pieces opens with E 4 and like
I already said we didn't cover the game
although we might Magnus 1 a very nice
game against nipple with the
Scandinavian opening so here he attempts
to do the same with that and there was a
pretty violent game so let's see how on
and the deals with the Scandinavian with
a capture screen captures and Knight to
c3 and here Queen to d6 the same as in
the line he played against nipple I
myself started playing this line of the
other Scandinavian against the 4 just to
try for fun and it's it's actually very
enjoyable
we have Knight to f3 continuing
development tonight if Knight f6 and now
d4 now we have c6 now taking care of any
Knights to be 5 ideas also if well if Y
decides to pick play maybe g3 Bishop g2
and gold Bishop to f4 you will not have
to worry about any Knight b5 idea so c6
a very useful move especially in the
Scandinavian with Bishop to d3 and now
Bishop to g4 going after the knight on
f3 Knight to e4 attacking the Queen
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
just Knight bb7 preparing Knight to f6
to assume the place of the other night
we have C 3 H 3 and Bishop to g5 are
known moves in the position but C 3 is a
new move in the position so already as a
move 9 we have a completely new game and
let's see how Magnus deals with Knight
back to f6 and Bishop to c2 now of
course not allowing the trade and here
Crossing goes Queen to d5 so this is the
idea he he wanted to use he's now ready
to trade off
Queens with Bishop captures an f3
Anand goes h3 he wants to check if if
Magnus really wants to trade Queens so
we have Bishop captures Queen captures
Queen captures pawn captures in the now
just east six preparing to bring the
other Bishop into the game as well so
here Magnus was able to mess up on on
spawn structure but as as a result he
had to give up the bishop pair whereas
Anand still has the bishop pair so a
nice trade-off with Bishop to g5 and now
Knight to d5 with Bishop to e4
activating the Bishop says as much as
possible and Bishop to d6 and here King
- II - of course you're not interested
in castling we are in the endgame so now
you want to the King in the center of
the board King e2 and the Magnus does
the same King these seven with Bishop
back the e3 and now g6
we have rook a to D 1 and here Magnus
continues with b5 who wants to push a5
and start pushing points on the Queen
side so here that onon spots that c4
could be a valuable pawn thrust so rogue
back to c1 and now a 5 we have c4 by an
intense e4 rook captures and now just
rook H to be 8 and here Magnus is
attacking the B to pawn it will fall
with check so you do have to defend it
rook H to be 1 and now look the b4 by
Magnus it is the most precise way to
play if you try a something like a 4
with ideas of pushing a 3 white can just
push a 3 you don't have Bishop captures
an a3 to pick up the rook because the
bishop also defends the row can be 1 so
not not a possibility after will be 1 we
have looked to be for island traits rook
captures and now pawn captures if Knight
captures going after the 8 upon just a 4
and white what White's position is fine
so here we have a capture some before
and now the a 2 point is under attack
we've looked at a 1 and now Knight
captures than e3 f captures and rook to
a5 with ideas of well going after the h3
pawn so we have F 4 by Anand now any
rook to h5 ideas can be met with Bishop
to g2 and here c5 just continuing to
push the pawns ideas are well
or just C 4 and C 3 creating a passed
pawn so D captures in c5 with the shop
captures on c5 and now Anand has to
decide how to get the rook into the game
you cannot move the rook because the
route character Sunday - and well if you
just wait you will you will run into a
lot of struggles for example better p7
to f6 you can go after the B to pawn so
you can - just wait and see what happens
so here on and the decides to give up
upon he plays a3 and okay B captures on
a3 be captures and an outburst of
character Sunday 3
of course the nagging is not interested
in rook captures on a3 to go into the
bishops of opposite colored and games so
Magnus wants to do rooks on the board as
long as possible and now King to f3 so
it's a 4 points Magnus three points
Vichy and Magnus says one point island
which has two point islands but the
points are on the same side of the board
so good good drawing chances for Anand
with King to e7 and now Bishop to d3 we
have kink the f6 Magnus improves the
activity of the King looked a - with E 5
and now Bishop to c4 threatening to
maybe character on e5 and then pick up
the f7 pawn but of course e captures an
f4 by Magnus it captures on f4 and now
rook the c5 going after the bishop we
look to see - if root characters yeah
you could also trade bishops but then
again
Anand is not interested in trading
bishops Anand once the trade rooks so
rook to c2 defending the bishop and rook
the c7 by Magnus
we have Bishop to b3 Anand offers a rook
trade and magnetic declines we rook the
c3 aligning the rook with the bishop
adjust Bishop b4 we have rooked the c6
with check King g7 and Bishop to c4 now
with f5 by Magnus now not allowing the
King to go further up the board and now
Bishop to e2 we've looked a seven trying
to infiltrate the back rank but now
Bishop to e6 just preventing that and
the King to h6 of course and still
finding how to how to try and do
something about this position where he
still up upon but it's not much we have
grouped the b6 attacking the bishop
Bishop to c5 we have
the c6 and now Bishop to g1 King g2
pushes the bishop back Bishop to d4 we
have King to g3 and the now rook to e7
with ideas of just going rookie three
check so rook the c-4 attacking the
bishop and the now rook III check we
have King to g2 and Bishop back to f6
now we have Bishop to b7 and now comes
Bishop to h4 with ideas of maybe rook
the g3 check or rook to e2 cherry
depending on what on in place
Anand goes Bishop to f3 prevents both
ideas and the now comes rook to b3
giving on under the move we have Bishop
to d1 and now rook the g3 with check
king h2 and then out rook back to d3
attacking the bishop wave Bishop to a
four and now rook the d2 with checks so
taking away as many squares as possible
from uh non-skin kink the g1 and now
rush up to g3 and here if you try
something like King if one to get away
from from any ugly checks it's really
not all that possible if King King if
one rook F to check King g1 and now you
could go into this captures captures and
captures where you will be down to pawns
but still the pawns are on the same set
of the board is the bishops opposite
opposite colors so maybe you will be
able to set up a blockade on the on the
light squares but it's it's hard to say
if this is some well known drawn endgame
maybe it is so I sorry about that
we have Bishop the c6 and now comes King
to h5 now Magnus wants to bring his King
as close as possible
Bishop to g2 and now comes King to h4
and here we have looked a four by Anand
so here black has a very decisive move
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this decisive idea for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds as
it is very instructive so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding a
breakthrough in the position and for
those you if you just want to enjoy a
show it's Bishop to f2 check point is
after the King moves let's say to f1 you
can just move the bishop and now you
have looked
have to check where you will either
force the King away from the bishop and
then pick up the bishop or you will have
to go after this check go here and then
you will have some very nasty
discoveries after you move the rook
so after this trip to F to check on
unplayed King to h2 instead and here
magnets just played Bishop to e3 and it
was in this position that Anand resigned
the game because here it's just a very
clean win for black we will show why
it's a very clean win for black you want
to you want to prevent will be just
being checkmated for example if you try
something like King to h1 it doesn't
work you have to play something you
cannot move the bishop as your paint
here so you have to move the King if you
want to move the brush up so you can
either move the King or the rook so
let's try moving the King first if you
move the King then you allow King g3 and
now it's just game over now
rogue d1 or rook captures and g2 are
both terrible threats you cannot prevent
both if you prevent one then you just
get rook captures here and whatever move
you play next move it is just rock h2
mate so moving the King doesn't work
after Bishop to e3 you could also try
wasting moves with the route of rock c4
is one possibility but it still doesn't
work Ruby - you can again start a try
wasting move with the rook and now g5
that's the point you want a break break
through here either by capturing and
then moving the King and pushing f3 or
if white captures this comes with check
but it's not a problem f4 and now you
have after King Capra's you have f3 so
it's hard to say rook c4 you can again
waste a move but King captures and g5
and now yeah f3 is threatened which
would win the bishop and g2 so now you
have to do something like taking h1 but
now you're getting made it King bee
rugby 1 check King H to Bishop the g1
check King h1 and now brush of the f2
check King h2 and Bishop the g3 will be
made or if you don't want to get made it
you could also try Bishop to f1 so if
rope captures you can go with a double
attack with King G - but now f3 prevents
the King from reaching the g2 Square and
the next move you will simply capture
the bishop and win the game so after
Bishop d3 and so this is lost and he
resigned the game on move 57
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it you could argue that we've been
showing too many crossing games from
this tournament but it's a way for a
very good reason it's just that he wins
so many games here it's it would be
unnatural not to show them here we have
the standings after three days of rapid
and one day of blitz you can see that
you can see that Magnus is leading the
tournament five full points ahead of
Hicker Nakamura in second place of
Magnus 21 and a half out of 2027 the
only bump in the road for him was that
lost ding but that was there was just a
brilliancy on this part that King March
was incredibly impressive but yeah
followed by Nakamura who if if it's even
possible for Magnus not to win this
tournament tomorrow Magnus will have to
lose five games for Nakamura to catch up
to him if Nakamura can win five games in
row for them just to equalize so it's
it's very unlikely that Magnus will not
win this tournament but okay followed by
Wesley with thirteen and a half then
with 13 onigiri twelve and a half ding
in Nepal and Anand Parekh Krishna with
twelve then eleven with eleven and with
it in last place with ten but tomorrow
when a one whole day of blitz so
everyone can still improve
understandings so once again I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Stephen green for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
checking up on a few more games from the
from the Blitz event checking up on your
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent race today